اذا رغم الاحتجاجات والاضرابات وحتى
التهديد الان بالاستمرار يبدو ان خطه
حكومه الرئيس الفرنسي ماكرون لاقرار هذا
المشروع مشروع قانون لتعديل نظام التقاعد
المثير للجدل في طريقها للاقرار اولى هذه
الخطوات جاءت بتمرير مجلس الشيوخ ماده
رئيسيه في مشروع القانون تنصه على رفع سن
التقاعد من 62 الى 64 عاما وذلك رغم معركه
اجرائيه حاده مع اليسار
من الاعضاء صوتوا لصالح رفع سن التقاعد
مقابل 115 عضوا صوت ضده وينصه مشروع
القانون على زياده مده الاشتراكات
المطلوبه في الضمان الاجتماعي من 42 عام
الى 43 عام لكي يحصل المتقاعد على معاشه
التقاعدي كاملا دون اي خصومات يقول
برلمانيون انه من المتوقع ووفقا لخطه
الحكومه ان يمرر البرلمان هذا القانون
بحلول السادس عشر من الشهر الجاري وقد
وصفت رئيسه الوزراء مشروع القانون
بالمتوازن والعادل حيث تعول حكومتها على
هذا الاصلاح لضمان تمويل نظام الضمان
الاجتماعي الذي يشكل احد ركائز النموذج
الاجتماعي الفرنسي وضمان عدم افلاسه فيما
تظهر الاستطلاعات ان غالبيه الفرنسيين
يعارضون الاصلاح ويصفونه بالظالم فيما دعت
النقابات العماليه
الى الانص ات الى رفض الشارع مهدده بمزيد
من الاضطرابات حتى العدول عن القانون